two objects into the empty reaches of
space that rest relative to one another
suddenly they blast apart how do their
notions of space and time alter with
respect to one another and what happens
when we try to bring them back together
again
this is dialect and this is why
solutions to the twin paradox aren't
really solutions at all okay so from my
perspective every second that passes I
stay in this place
yeah that's not possible the distance
between there are a lot of videos on
YouTube claiming to have solutions to
the twin paradox unfortunately almost
all of these videos or at least the more
popular ones are just kind of wrong okay
that's not entirely the case it's not
that their solutions are wrong it's that
their solutions aren't solutions to the
right problem it's that these videos
don't even realize what the problem is
that they are trying to solve
it's not even just YouTube videos
textbooks internet pages popular books
they often have the same issue as they
struggle to explain away the paradox
often obfuscating their answer with
complex jargon diagrams or math they
each overlook one crucial point to
understand what that point is let's
return to our setup consider a universe
consisting of two objects we'll name
these objects Alice and Bob now these
objects suddenly accelerate apart
according to relativity there are now
two distinct perspectives to consider
first Alice's perspective she can claim
she's at rest in which case
Bob's clocks will slow down as he speeds
away and he will appear to age more
slowly than her secondly there's Bob's
perspective he can claim he's at rest as
well and in which case Alice's clocks
will be the ones slowing down as she
speeds away and she will appear to age
more slowly than he does now as long as
everyone travels at constant velocity
away from each other this will be a
happy universe with no logical
inconsistencies these objects will
merely agree to disagree on each other's
respective time intervals and then go
their separate ways
but what if one or both of the objects
suddenly turns around and then Alice and
Bob are brought back together again
if we remain analysis perspective Bob
will have aged less if we remain in
Bob's perspective Alice will be the one
who has aged less so of course the
paradox asks who is truly older Alice or
Bob there are two equally valid
symmetrical perspectives here but we can
only have one reality note here that we
don't discuss why time dilation occurs
there's plenty of other videos out there
that do a great job of this the main
thing that's important to understand
before going forward is that Alice and
Bob won't agree on who is older and it's
very unclear how they'd be able to
reconcile this difference so how do
other videos solve this paradox then
let's take a look first it is important
to note that these other videos
formulate the problem in a different way
they start with the premise that one
twin is located on earth while the other
accelerates away in a rocket ship why is
this difference important well let's
start by noting that the addition of
Earth is arbitrary it doesn't enter into
the math or the equations in any way so
in fact it's fair to get rid of the
earth altogether and just have the two
twins in an empty region of space
additionally the whole rocket ship
context is pretty superfluous we can
just consider two nondescript objects
that break apart and come back together
again this will still be after all the
twin paradox keep this difference in
formulation in mind we'll come back to
it okay so now we're going to take a
look at three different videos obviously
we don't have time to watch them in full
length though I recommend that you do
instead I'm going to skip straight to
snippets of the videos where they
identify exactly what their so-called
solution to the twin paradox really is
seconds and this is the resolution to
the twins paradox because you changed
velocity your notion of simultaneous
times rotates so you're accounting of
how time passes in parts of the universe
far away from you will have gaps in it
so how do we solve this paradox well the
answer lies in the details when your
twin turns around she has to accelerate
which means she's no longer in an
inertial reference frame while she
accelerates and so special relativity no
longer applies to her
when Adam fires his rockets to turn
around
he is extremely far away from the earth
therefore Adam will believe that the
gravitational field is causing time on
earth to flow much faster than time on
his ship
but what about Sarah's point of view
from Sarah's point of view this external
gravitational field never existed
all right let's review each of these
videos posits a cause for the breaking
of the symmetry of the twin paradox that
is they give a reason why one twin is
older than the other
the reason itself is pretty easy to
pinpoint let's review video by video
first we have minutephysics which is by
far the most popular of the videos his
answer is Ward for award that you
meaning the space traveling twin changed
velocity meaning accelerated physics
girls answer is basically the same she
says when your twin turns around she has
to accelerate last we had the video by
Eugene and I'm not even attempt to
butcher that name his videos are very
very smart some of the best videos
you'll find about physics on YouTube so
I was actually pretty disappointed when
I watched this video he basically gives
the same answer
however he cloaks it in a discussion of
general relativity and how that is
formulated differently than special
relativity but the basic answer is the
same it comes at the point when he says
when Adam fires his rockets this is
essentially indicating that it is Adam
the space going twin who is the one who
accelerates and that's the cause for him
seeing a time dilating gravitational
field while the earthbound twins he's
nothing so here we had three different
videos all with the same answer they all
say that it is the space traveling twin
who accelerates and this is what causes
the breaking of the symmetry but there's
an incredible assumption here and that
assumption is acceleration is absolute
that is each of these videos posits that
all observers will agree that it is the
space traveling twin who's the one who
really accelerates while the earthbound
twin does not this assumption is
profoundly unreal atavistic it boggles
my mind the whole point of relativity is
that there are no preferred frames of
motion each twin has an equal right to
say that it is the other twin who
accelerated or turned around or fired
his rockets in general relativity it is
not just the Apple that falls to the
earth it is also the earth that falls to
the Apple both points of view are
equally valid that is why it is so
important to consider our initial setup
in which we have a universe with only
two objects that Bray
apart and come back together again there
is nothing else in this universe for
these objects to move relative to so
what's to decide whether one object's
acceleration was really more real than
the others the answer is there isn't in
this scenario there is no objective way
to determine which object will be older
when the two are recombined now when you
have this set up with earth and rocket
ships it seems much more obvious who's
the one who's accelerating right this is
because you no longer have the same
symmetry that you did in the two object
universe but the symmetry of this
situation is not broken by acceleration
it is broken by the addition of the
earth and the fixed stars this is the
crucial point that the other videos
overlook we can't say that the space
traveling twin is absolutely the one who
accelerates we can say that the space
traveling twin accelerates relative to
the earth and the rest of the fixed
stars that is why these other videos
don't get it right they go ahead and
assign one of the twins accelerations as
being absolute without offering any
justification for doing so they don't
understand what the twin paradox is
about the twin paradox isn't about hey
who's gonna be older Alice or Bob if
we've already decided that it's Bob
who's really accelerating it's pretty
easy to show that answer is Alice the
actual paradox is about why the space
going twins acceleration is more real
than as counterparts and that's the kind
of question that doesn't have an easy
answer it involves exploring ideas of
mass and inertia but that's why at the
end of the day these so-called solutions
to the twin paradox are highly
misleading they are right only in the
most superficial sense this is why most
people who are new to the subject
after hearing so-called solutions still
come away with an intuitive sense of
skepticism because the twin paradox is
actually still a paradox well that's all
for now
this has been dialect thanks for
watching